Ricardo, Nick,
congratulations.
You guys have made it
into the final round
of this competition.
Now, we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate this iconic
weapon from history.
The ikakalaka.
Heading off the weapon.
ARMORER: Weapon's hot.
Today, we are
protesting the ikakalaka.
So the ikakalaka is
a very unique sword.
Looking at Dave's
weapon, I'm thinking,
oh, it's gonna be one of
those heavy weapons again.
And I pick it up
and I'm like, no.
It's not.
You have a distal taper
that goes down there.
So the weight is not at the tip.
I was pleasantly surprised.
Forged by the Mongo tribe
in the kingdom of Lunda
during the early 1800s,
the ikakalaka was
a fierce and imposing weapon.
Designed for executions,
the double-edged blade
featured a thick spine
and large crescent
tip, giving it the ability
to forcibly chop with ease.
This powerful weapon
with an ornate shape
quickly became
associated with wealth,
dignity, and social
position among men and women
in the Mongo tribe.
The ikakalaka can be seen
in the 2018 blockbuster
film "Black Panther."
That crescent edge
acts like an ax head,
but you're thrusting
with the ax head.
And then, you have the shaft, or
the length, of the blade there
that's double edge.
Then, you can get
deep cuts with that.
It's just like a sword, except
it's got a spatulated tip
that I can thrust with.
When you pick up the
weapon and it works and it
functions the way
it was made to be,
it tells me a lot
about the smith.
That means he not only
knows how to make it,
he understands why he made it.
That's bladesmithing.
[blade whacking]
So having the crescent
head also gives
you some curved edges to that.
So one of the things
we're worried about
is you can get snagged.
One, two, three, a point.
So in wielding this, if I'm
gonna be slashing or chopping
something, I gotta make
sure that I use the shaft
and avoid the tip.
If I'm thrusting
with it, no problem.
OK.
The whole weapon has to work.
[squirts]
Good luck.
We'll see you in four days.
NICK HICKS: My
name is Nick Hicks.
What I like most
about bladesmithing
is the artwork behind it.
Being able to take
something most folks would
look at as a piece
of junk and turn it
into something beautiful
and usable, I think,
is the ultimate artwork.
I cut the 80c RV at an angle
to establish my scarf weld,
so that when I stack
those billets up together,
I'm going to try and mold those
down into the original blade
to make a crescent.
All right.
Slowly but surely.
Plan is move a lot of steel.
Get this thing shaped,
hopefully quenched.
It's gonna be a
big, heavy blade.
The weapon was made
as a serious chopper.
It will be heavy.
But when you get
it in your hands,
it will be a commanding tool.
I'm gonna make sure our quench
tank is gonna accept this.
Looks pretty good.
The time is definitely
an issue here.
So I have to get
this thing quenched.
I think we're pretty good.
I'm elated.
It's straight.
So I'm feeling great right now.
So I'm gonna to take
the black walnut.
I'm gonna start working it up.
We've got to get this
hourglass design into it.
We're gonna put a butt
cap on or a pommel cap.
And then, we're gonna
weld it and attach
it up so that it'll be strong
and tight and ready to go.
I want the end of my handle to
be protected as much as I can.
I've got everything
all together.
So now, just comes, really,
working on that edge
as much as I can.
I feel a tremendous weight
lifted off of my shoulders.
RICARDO: My name
is Ricardo Vilar.
I'm originally from Brazil.
I immigrated to
US two years ago.
In Brazil, people know
about me and my knives.
But in America, nobody knows me.
If I do well in this
competition, people in America
are probably gonna
know my name too.
I'm using water
on the anvil, just
to make the tip a little cooler.
This is a very old technique
to give me the control
to make the shoulders better.
The tip is done.
Time to get into the oil.
That's hard.
I have a blade that's
good to turn in.
But I think I can do better.
So let's turn on the
forge and start over.
I love so much this job
that I'm making twice.
What took me hours before has
just took me minutes this time.
And now, I'm done.
I love when a plan
comes together.
I quench the second blade.
The blade is straight.
It's hard.
And I'm much more confident
in the second product.
So the second one is the
one I'm gonna compete with.
What I did different
in this blade
is it has a different edge
geometry and a harder taper.
Everything is coming together.
Now, it's time to go and see
how does it gonna perform?
For me, it's OK.
I'm happy.
All right, bladesmiths.
Welcome to the kill test.
Well, your ikakalakas look
interesting and exotic.
But what kind of lethal
damage can they do?
Well, to find that out,
I'm gonna take your weapon,
deliver some lethal blows
on this ballistics dummy.
Ricardo, you're up first.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
I'm ready.
Let's go for it.
[rock music]
All right, Ricardo, I
like-a your ikakalaka.
Thank you.
It's got a good weight to it.
The handle construction
is comfortable.
When you're swinging
this, it digs deep.
That is a sharp edge.
And when you're
penetrating, it really
digs and cuts on the way out.
Overall, sir, it will kill.
Thank you, sir.
All right, Nick, your turn.
So are you ready?
I'm ready.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Let's do this.
Ricardo's ikakalaka is
everything I expected, light,
fast, a well-made weapon.
But my confidence
level is pretty good.
I'm fairly confident that
my blade will succeed.
The minute you
pick up this weapon,
I feel the stress on my wrist,
my elbows, and my shoulder.
It's so forward heavy.
Tell me what you feel.
Front of the shoulder.
I'm trying to swing
this over and over.
It's gonna be tough.
It's not looking good.
Nick, due to the extreme
weight of your ikakalaka,
the judges feel that it would
be unsafe to attempt to wield it
in the same manner
that they wielded
Ricardo's one-handed blade.
And because we can't test it
evenly and fairly, we cannot
move forward with testing.
I'd like to invite you
to shake our hands,
shake your competitor's hand,
and then please exit the Forge.
Just totally disappointed.
Sorry about that.
NICK: I wanted them to
really test that weapon.
I had a lot of faith in it.
I knew it was heavy, but
one little mistake like this
is something I'm gonna
learn on and build.
And it's gonna make
me a better smith.
Well, Ricardo,
congratulations.
You are the new Forged
in Fire Champion.
And that is a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Come on forward.
Good job.
It's a great weapon.
This is great.
This is amazing.
Being the champion is you
can trust what I'm doing.
You can trust on my blades.
You can trust on my work.
I'm really, really happy
to be the champion.
[music playing]